hello everyone and welcome back to the
kappa blanka saga we are back at the
1916 tournament in New York is the rice
Memorial Tournament and this is the last
game will be showing from this
tournament it's a very special game for
a few reasons but we're gonna talk more
about that after we check out the game
Capablanca has the white pieces he faces
a very strong American chess master or
Oscar Haas and in 1909 hiso won the US
Open Championship so he's a very strong
player he played future matches against
Davi Janoski he lost the first one he
won the second one so yeah definitely a
strong player and this game it really
will show you how strong he is
so without further adue heist has the
white pieces and he opens with efore
with a sex kappa blanka goes for the
French defense with d4 d5 and now Knight
to c3 with Knight to f6 by capablanca
and the Bishop to g5 a very sharp line
with Bishop to b4 and now comes a five
by highest with h6 and now White has a
few options you can go Bishop back all
the way back to D - you can go Bishop
before you can go Bishop h4 you can
capture here you can capture like this
but then you get bone captures here F
captors and rook here and all over the
is playable but highest goes for Bishop
to b2 he just retreats with the bishop
Capablanca captures on c3 we had the
shock captures be captures and now comes
Knight to e4 just an excellent square
for the knight it will not be easy to
dislodge it from there and well with
Queen to g4 by highest standard and
motive against the French going after
the g7 pawn I soak up the Blanca
defences King to f8 now later he's gonna
go g6 King to g7 and tried to bring the
rook into the game that way so he still
will be able to castle artificially at
least Bishop the c1 white doesn't allow
a couple of uncut the capture on d2 and
he wants this Bishop to also be able to
deliver this Bishop to a3 check if
needed but now Capablanca needs to
decide this you want to grab a seat or a
pawn he doesn't he continues in a
principled matter just c5 continuous
development attacks White's
very strong center
and he does want to open lines as a
white King is still stuck in the center
Bishop to d3 by Haas continues
developing and now Queen to a5 a very
nice move
threatening C capture son before as the
C pawn is pinned also white black and
just capture on c3 so Knight to e2 you
have to defend this pawn and here you
have to decide again what do you want to
do if you play Knight captures on c3
then yes you will win some material but
white will get a lot out of it after
Bishop to b2 just pinning the night and
now okay C capture Sundy for protecting
tonight but now white can just go Knight
captures on d4 and you constantly have
to keep an eye on this pin it's very
uncomfortable if you play Queen c7 just
getting out of the pin what can just
Castle and the White has an excellent
development for the price of one point
f4 f5 is coming and it will be a very
unpleasant position to play for black so
after this night Stewie to move couple
bunkers were see captures on d4 first we
have castles by highest and now comes
the D captures on c3 cover Michael grabs
another pawn and now Bishop captures on
e4 pawn captures and now Queen captures
on e4 and here just Knight to c6
you need to continue developing pieces
also the threat is Queen captures on e5
which just would well black would just
be better here so rook to d1 preventing
Queen captures on e5 with the idea that
if Queen does capture then Ruby d8 check
wins the game for white now you can't
capture with the night because the
knight defends the Queen here you have
to move the King and now just captures
captures and you lose the rook on h8 so
after this rook to d1 move with g6
backup of Blanca preparing the castle
artificially f4 defending the e5 pawn
and now comes King to g7 with Bishop to
e3 by white and now capablanca has some
issues with the development of this
light square bishop the rook still
guards the d7 square so you have to
figure out how to do a couple Blanca
finds are very nice when Knights the e7
he wants to go to d5 to block the rooks
control over the d7 square and develop
the bishop this way so night is coming
here and the bishop will go for example
there should be seven c6 and it will be
on a very nice
here with Bishop 2f2 and now comes nice
the d5 as planned and here now that the
bishop retrievers - f - I've made room
for this very nice rock lift will group
the d3 the rook is now coming to g3 and
then ideas like f5 will be possible h4 8
h5 will be an idea he wants to start an
attack against couple Blancas King
Bishop to d7 couple Blanca continuous
development and now Knights the d4 just
bringing yet another piece into the
attack we have rook a to c8 kappa blanka
again just continues development and now
rook to g3 so you can see there's a lot
of pressure going on around couple
Blancas King f5 now is the idea f as the
G pawn is pinned you will not be able to
capture so first kappa blanka gets the
king out of the way King to h7 but now
the king is undisturbed '''l now the G
point is the once again pin so highest
tries to attack it with the H bone with
H 4 now comes rook H to g8 with the idea
of defending the g6 pawn and now just h5
the pony still pinned Shaka palanca is
unable to react to this and here we have
Queen to b4 preventing this Knight from
moving as Queen captures Queen would
happen and also maybe if if white is too
slow then you can even go back and try
and use the Queen as a defender with
Queen to e7 but here we have looked to
h3 now the the idea is switched over to
the H file and it is all made possible
by kapa Blancas move Queen to b4 and
here now a couple Blancas position is
defendable and it's it's a very nice
position even though it looks disgusting
but you want to go nicely 7 just keep an
eye on the g6 pawn and well continue
playing the game here at Capablanca
played a bit more - a bit to actively he
played f5 and he allowed the the next
series of moves he captures on f6 on
poisson with Knight captures on f6 and
now H captures and g6 with check
we have rook captures on g6 and now feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the best continuation for white
here I'll give you a couple of seconds
to decide whether you want to do
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are one step closer
to beating josé raúl capablanca and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show
sorry about that rook captures on h6 the
rook on g6 is pinned and you have to
capture there's no option of moving the
King because Queen captures rook on g6
so you have to capture with a king and
now Knight f5 check finally this Queen
will now be will now be one with each
captures on f5 as the king is in check
and now finally Queen captures screen on
before but it's not all that big of a
big of a deal because Capablanca still
has a lot of counter play and here
capablanca mentions that he was
considering it are just rook a rook C to
g8 and just putting more pressure on the
G file or does he want to go Bishop to
c6 first because if Bishop to c6 then
white will lose a valuable tempo as rook
to d1 will not come as a wooden an
attack against the bishop on d7 so here
you would have to go g3 just defending
that g3 pawn and now you would get
nicely to h5 continuing the attack or
nice the e4 would be very strong just
going after the bishop and it's just a
very powerful position for black but
here kappa blanka decided he wants to go
rook to g8 immediately threatening to
capture on g2 with g3 and now bishop the
c6 so it's a different order moves but
now rook to d1 comes and nevertheless
and here is the problem
Knights the e4 is still playable but
here Kappa Blanco was worried about rook
to d6 but it shouldn't be a problem for
black here if nice to e4 going after the
bishop here now rook to d3
just defending the g3 pawn and now you
can trade everything here Knight
captures rook captures and now if route
captures Bishop captures rook captures
with check King to h2 and not just to
rook the g2 check and here you would
have sufficient
well sufficient resources to draw this
game with black king h1 is not possible
as all sorts of nasty discoveries become
possible you would have to go to h3 and
I'll just throw captures on c2 Cooper
Blanca would even get a pass C pawn but
after Queen d6 check
you can see that it will now be very
very difficult to escape checks from the
White Queen let's say King g8 Queen g5
check King can go to h8 not on screen
captures an f5 attacks the rook after
lure the rook moves now you could get
Queen to a fete and you will not be able
to escape checks from the White Queen
so kappa blanka is not interested in
this drawn line that we've just shown so
he goes into H into H 5 most likely with
the idea that after the shown variation
Queen to d6 does not come with check and
he can just continue his attack but rook
to d6 and now we have Bishop the e4
going after the sea to pawn also
defending the f5 pawn Queen captures on
c3 now with a double attack against the
night here and now Knight to d5 opening
up an attack towards a high screen and
also an attack towards his rook but here
we have an excellent move rook captures
sorry rook captures on g6 and now if
Capablanca captures the Queen rook
captures rook Knight captures pawn and
Bishop captures pawn and you get the
same game both players have two points
but high still has a rook and Bishop
against a bishop in the night so it
would be a winning endgame for white so
a couple blanca has to capture the rook
we have King captures on g6 and now
comes Queen to e5 and just King to f7
opening up this file for the rook we
have c4 kicking away the night now comes
Luke to e8 attacking the Queen Queen to
be to putting pressure under b7 pawn and
now just nice to have six getting the
right out of the way also the Bishop
from efore guards the b7 pawn so you can
see that the bishop is very useful there
Bishop to d4 now before capturing an a7
pressuring the night here and now just
look to h8 cover Blancas idea is that
okay now if Bishop captures now rook to
h1 checking if to location to check will
win back the Queen after King III rogue
captures Bishop captures and even though
Capablanca would be down upon here he is
confident he would hold this position as
it's a i NN game of opposites called
bishops white is up upon but black will
be able to draw so after Bishop to b4 we
have worked to h8 as we
set and now Queen to be five of course
highest does not go for for this capture
and here we just look to h1 by kappa
blanka
with King to f2 and now a six and you
can see how color Blancas pieces are
placed very harmoniously the bishop on
e4 is just a monster the knight defends
it also the pawn defends that the bishop
defends the base of the pawn chain that
b7 pawn the B Simone defends the a
sexpot so there doesn't seem to be a
good way for whites to make a
breakthrough but Queen to b6 the thread
is Queen captures on f6 now and now you
have two choices either you go route
cage to check or you go rook h6 with the
threat of 94 check winning the Queen and
it's a very nice line but it doesn't end
the world for capablanca as after Queen
to c7 check King to f8 now you get the
Bishop to c5 check King to g8 now comes
Queen to d8 check King to have 7 and now
Queen to f8 check going after the rook
here came to g6 defending the rook and
now push up to d4 with the idea of
capturing the night here Knights to g4
check King to e2 and now finally you do
have to play something as there are
other threats here after King to h5
trying to hide now Queen to e7 is very
strong and there's really nothing you
can do to defend checkmate if you try
rope g6 then Queen to h4 is checkmate
because now the rope doesn't fall out
the King to escape via the g6 Square so
look to h6 although seems like a very
nice defensive resource doesn't really
work so couple Blanca goes for the other
one we look to HD check King to e1 and
the now comes Knight to d7 just getting
the knight out of harm's way attacking
the Queen on d6 Queen to d6 and now
comes Bishop a back to c6 defending the
knight and here Capablanca managed to
keep everything in order but now his
pieces are a bit bit more passive and it
allows highest
finally continued his attack we have G
for forcing couple Blanca to capture
otherwise G otherwise g5 is coming so
captures and now f5 and now you can see
that a lot of squares around the black
King are no longer available to him and
of course white will use that according
we look to h1 check first thing to d2
and now kink the eh
we have f6 now and just rook to h7
keeping an eye on the f7 squared
Queen the e6 check King to f8 and now
comes Bishop to e3 with a deadly a
threat if capablanca isn't careful here
for example if he starts pushing his
pawn and then of course you will see the
maid threat it's a very nice mating
three
I'll even let you find it if you're
interested you know pause the video and
such for those who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
checkmater in three and for those who
just want to enjoy the show Bishop to h6
is the plan you just give up your Bishop
and then the g7 square is no longer
covered just Queen d7 check King g8 and
Queen to g7 will be checkmate this was
the idea behind this Bishop to e3 move
capablanca spots that he goes look to f7
now the Queen and now the King can
retreat to the g8 square Bishop to h6
check with King to g8 and now after the
game kappa blanka said that he was
considering resigning here but he
decided to continue the game as he he
was hoping to see the following line
Queen captures on g4 with check after
the King moves attacks the bishop now
Queen h5 threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries and after rook captures on
f6 as the rook is also under attack now
Bishop to g5 will win the rook but this
is what Capablanca was hoping for King
g7 Bishop captures on f6 skin captures
on f6 and here what White has a queen
but black has a knight a bishop and two
pawns in it will be very hard to pick
them off and Capablanca says that if you
don't if you think this is easily
winnable would white
try and play this position against the
master and you will be proven otherwise
but highest doesn't go for this he
doesn't grab the pawn he goes Bishop to
g7 now the the ideas just gets the Queen
around just it'll maybe like this and
then bring the Queen over to the h8
square deliver checkmate or after a cup
of moong has moved g3 now you also have
the ability of going Queen to h3 but
Phi's first I decided to block the pawn
with the King we have King to e2 not
jeetu the pawn is defended by the bishop
and now king - f - now the king defends
the G 1 square and knights the f8 kickin
the Queen away we have Queen to G for
now again with all sorts of discoveries
possible Knight to d7 making some room
for the king if the bishop decides to
move let's say to h8 although it's it's
a weird idea and not just into g1
blocking the pawn all the way with a 5
by kappa blanka and now a 4 first
highest decides okay maybe you just want
to capture here so I can capture the Jie
du Pont and couple of assists okay let's
let's do that with Bishop captures on a4
and I'll just the Queen to h3
threatening checkmate and now capablanca
has to capture either the bishop or the
pawn on f6 he decides to go for the pawn
with roof captures on f6 and now comes
in Bishop captures on f6 Knight captures
on f6 and now Queen captures on g2 with
check King to f8 and now Queen captures
on b7 with bishop - eh retreating with
the bishop and now Queen to b6 is going
after the last pawn king to e7 Queen
captures on a5 by highest we have Knight
to d7 and now King to f2 he just starts
bringing his King into the game Bishop
to f7 now comes King to e3 of course the
pawn is immune to capture because Queen
before check just picks it up as you can
see so King to b6 was played and now
comes King to d4 here we have King to c6
and here in this position has just
played Queen to f5 and it was in this
position that josé raúl capablanca
resigned the game unmoved 66 because his
Bishop is trapped and the game is of
course lost there's nowhere to go you
can go here but then just win g6 check
picks up the bishop and well let's say
this happens I have a queen and pawn
against tonight and of course even
Capablanca isn't that strong to continue
playing this game but yeah I like
Capablanca said he he did consider
resigning long ago all the way on no 50
as he was hoping for this line but you
know yeah you have to hope that your
opponent will blunder if there's you
know richness in the position if it's
possible to use combinations to get out
of
tricky situations but here has just
played a perfect game and here this is a
from Kappa Blancas book were Coco Blanca
mentions this game he says a fighting
game on highest part from move 25 on 4
while black having the best of the
position missed several chances white on
the other hand missed none so white
indeed played an excellent game there
were really not even well maybe
inaccuracies but definitely not mistakes
or blunders and that's what you need to
do to defeat Jose roll kappa blanka but
then again on the other hand he played
the French and even you know without
studying opening theory no one even come
along it's been good enough to play the
French sure that's pretty much it for
this game and it's interestingly this is
a the last game capablanca will lose for
a very long time i will not mention for
how long if you need to chest maybe it
will spoil the rest of the Capablanca
saga for you but you know when i say a
long time i mean a very long time and
here is basically the beginning of
couple one castle legendary unbeaten
streak and we do have the standings let
me just not forget that here are the
standings of the rice Memorial
Tournament of 1916 in new york so let's
check it out
first place of course as expected whole
Soroka blanca 14 out of 17 points 12
wins 1 only 1 loss the 1 - Oscar highs
and 4 draws 3 whole points ahead of
second place doggy on offski 11 out of
17 8 wins 3 losses and six draws and
Oscar highs after winning this game
against Capablanca 10 and 1/2 out of 17
8 wins 4 losses and 5 draws so the three
of them in top 3 places then we have
Abraham koopchick
borislav caustic then Jacob Rosenthal
jakob bernstein albert whiting fox
alfred shredder
albert hodge roy Trimble black edwards
tenon versatile Frank Kendall Perkins
and noble William banks in last place
with 2 out of 13 so that's basically it
for this rice Memorial Tournament of
1916 I still haven't decided where we're
going with a couple bunker stock I will
decide tomorrow and then we are
continuing so we will either visit one
more tournament or go straight for the
for the World Chess Championship match
with Emmanuel Lasker if you if you feel
like it you can even
you know leave a comment and and mention
if you would like to you know check out
a few more tournaments or maybe just one
more tournament before the championship
game last and match with Lasker or you
want to go straight into the match with
Lasker but yeah yeah that's it I do hope
you enjoyed it
and you know don't if you're not really
into opening theory don't play the
French I would like to thank Irina Sonam
of Gleb come check off KD Nuggets Robert
Young Quest and Nikolas Kron for a
conclusion to my channel thinking what
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check - in my previous videos here think
all for watching and I will see you soon
most likely continuing the capablanca
saga but as usual checking up in your
suggestions and and what happens in the
world
yeah thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
Saturday